good evening everybody this is a meeting
of the planning and development
management committee of trafford council
my name is ben hartley i'm the chair of
the committee on my immediate rights is
the vice chair of the committee
councillor barry winstonly uh to my left
and right at this end of the table there
are
offices from the council from the
planning team and the highways team and
the legal team and then further around
the table are members of the planning
committee who are all local councillors
and i'll introduce each of them
as and when they wish to speak on an
item
item one on the agenda is attendances
and apologies for absence i know we've
had apologies from
councillor morgan uh and i i don't think
we have a substitute for councillor
morgan and
councillor dagnall i think he's going to
be late
so we'll get started and then when
councillor dagnall joins she can join
the next item that we that we start
um item number two on the agenda is to
is the uh standard membership including
the chair vice chair and opposition
spokesperson of the planning and
development management committee for the
municipal year 2022-23
as agreed by the council at its meeting
on 25th may uh
2022 so
there is a list of the committee members
in the uh agenda pack um
so councillor chalking you're going to
be the opposition spokesperson i believe
uh and welcome i think the only new
member completely new is probably
councillor procter so welcome council
proctor i hope you enjoy your time here
and returning
is councillor walsh who i know has been
on the committee before so uh welcome
councillor walsh um
item number three is the appointment of
a subcommittee so the committee is asked
to appoint the tone village green
subcommittee comprising the chair
vice chair and opposition spokesperson
or their nominees for the municipal year
at 2022 2020
uh are members in agreement with
appointing that subcommittee
yes yeah hi thank you not seeing any
dissent item number four is terms of
reference and it's to note the terms of
reference
for the planning and development
management committee
and again you'll find those in your
in your agenda
reports pack
moving on item number five is the
meeting dates and it's to note the uh
schedule meeting dates for the committee
uh during this uh municipal year again
as agreed by the council on the 25th may
2022 and i won't read the dates out but
i know that members will be aware of
those dates already
item number six is declarations of
interest and this is for members to give
notice of any personal or prejudicial
interest and the nature of that interest
relating to any item on the agenda in
accordance with the adopted code of
conduct are any members looking to
declare an interest at this stage
no okay
good move on item number seven is
minutes it's to receive
and if so determined to approve as a
correct record the minutes of the
meetings held on the 12th and the 23rd
of may uh 2022.
i'm just looking for council thomas
you're happy to move that over here
thank you um
so when stanley happened a second thank
you so
uh those minutes are approved
uh i've seen number eight is questions
from members of the public so a maximum
of 15 minutes is allocated to public
questions
submitted in writing to democratic
services by 4 pm two working days prior
to the meeting questions must be within
the remit of the committee or be
relevant to items appearing on the
agenda and will be submitted in the
order in which they were received
i don't believe we have any questions
from members of the public i've not been
notified of any
okay thank you so we'll move on item
number nine is the additional
information report and it's to consider
the report um with additional
information for the applications
um which has been tabled so that was
emailed to members earlier today and i
think hard copies are also
uh available if anybody's not got one
available then uh please do shout up
okay moving on now to item number 10
which is application for permission to
develop
and it's to consider um attached reports
from the head of planning and
development
um for four applications this evening
and before we move on to the first
application i just want to explain for
anybody in the room and anybody watching
the procedure will will follow with each
of the applications
and so on each application will first of
all have
a presentation and an introduction from
a member of the planning team
and once we've had that introduction
on some of the items we may then have
speakers boast both for and against the
proposal and we'll hear from the
speakers against the proposal first um
members of the public if you're here to
speak on an item you'll have three
minutes to speak on the item
uh councillors if you're here to speak
on an item you'll have uh five minutes
uh when we've heard from those speakers
for and against then i'll open the
debate up to members of the committee
and i'll introduce them as and when they
wish to comment and just to say that
members of the committee cannot usually
uh engage with the speakers so we can't
usually ask you questions and you can't
usually ask those questions so we may do
that in exceptional circumstances but
that is uh certainly not the norm
so we'll just uh we'll move on first of
all to
application 105 654 which is the former
cartwright group site on atlantic street
in altering them
and we're just going to get the
presentation up and running so we'll
just pause for a moment
just if you just bear with us yeah no
problem
for members of the committee the papers
for this start on page 19
and the presentation that we'll have
will be from mr pearson once we're up
and running
[Music]
that's not what's nice for me as you can
see
[Music]
can i check is mr greenbank here to
speak on this
item we've got statement we've got a
stem from him there's mr winter here
yeah okay we'll be with you in a moment
then mr winter
[Music]
thank you chairman yes um
so this application um relates to the
former cartwright site on atlantic
street
in the broad heath industrial estate
and as you can see um from that first
slide this is a major industrial
employment park we've gone and lost the
display again unfortunately
okay
well you have to bear with me we did
have a nice set of slides for you but um
the application site is a large one it's
approximately 4.7 hectares in area
and it's historically been used for
general industrial use and up until
recently was occupied by the cartwright
group which was involved in the
commercial vehicle trailer manufacturing
however following the company's
administration in september 2020 the
site has been vacant
the site surrounded by industrial and
employment uses to the east north and
west whilst on the southern side of the
canal is residential development
there are a number of large steel framed
industrial buildings on the site
some of those buildings are currently in
the process of being demolished
following a recent prior approval
application
can you scroll down to the site yeah the
application proposes the comprehensive
redevelopment of the site following the
demolition works
two of the existing units unit a and b
are proposed to be retained and extended
and refurbished and there are five new
industrial units proposed those are
units c to f along the southern side of
your screen and then up the the right
hand side
the use of the site is proposed for
general industrial storage and
distribution research and development
and in the industrial processes that are
appropriate in a residential area
and ancillary office use
vehicular access to the site is
currently taken from atlantic street
with one access serving the former staff
car park area of cartwrights and a
second access for larger vehicles such
as hgvs hgvs
a new vehicle access is proposed located
towards the northeastern extremity of
the site boundary with atlantic street
uh whilst the existing car park
vehicular access will be closed
the application proposes the use of the
site 24 hours a day for 365 days a year
a total of 316 parking spaces car
parking spaces are proposed which
includes 22 electric charging spaces and
35 accessible parking spaces
during the course of the application the
applicant has amended the layout of the
units along the southern boundary of the
site to address concerns from local
residents and officers regarding noise
from activity on the site particularly
in the external areas of the site
the new layout which you see be on the
screen now includes units along that
southern boundary so that the surface
shards face into the site
with the new units acting as a physical
barrier to screen noise and activity
from the residential areas on the other
side of the canal
if you go down again
in terms of their appearance the units
will be clad in in a gray cladding
material and look like typical
industrial units there's a few um slides
of floor plans and
uh elevations
and then we've got a few photographs of
the site
um
if you yeah of the existing site from
atlantic street
um and again
and then there's unit a to be retained
and extended
unit b
yeah we keep scrolling um that shows the
tree screen to the southern and western
boundary of the site
uh some of the trees on the western
boundary will be removed
and that shows the the southern boundary
of the site from the opposite side of
the canal so it's effectively from the
residential properties
and that's looking back the other way
from the tow path towards the
residential properties
so the use is considered to be
acceptable in principle matters such as
the scale and design of the buildings
along with matters relating to highways
ecology trees and landscaping drainage
and contamination have all been
considered and found to be acceptable
subject to appropriate conditions
following the amendments
undertaken the proposed layout is now
considered to be acceptable with regards
to residential amenity
significant weight is attached to the
fallback position which is that the site
can operate as a general industrial use
with no restrictions
on the hours of use which was the case
with the former site when operated by
cartwrights
so the application's therefore
recommended for approval
there are some additional points in the
additional information reports
um perhaps that one of the key ones
being the the reference to the likely
employment generation uh of the scheme
it's estimated to be somewhere in the
region of 380 full-time jobs
which would go some way towards
replacing the approximately 650 jobs
that were lost at cartwrights
thank you jen
thank you mr pearson uh councillor
jerome um
do you want to come up to the microphone
ready to speak
so i know you've
been a member of the committee before
councillor jerome so you'll know
what happens um
and although the site is in broad heath
and
obviously i know your counselor for
altering him um
the nearest sort of residential
area is on the other side of canal and
altering ward so uh yeah that's that's
why you're here and you've got five
minutes to speak once you start talking
thank you
thanks chair uh committee members and
officers for allowing me to speak i'm
here to echo the fears of residents
about the many uncertainties that are
present in this application
as some of you will know the site was
formerly occupied by the cartwrights
group as a campaigner and then
councillor for altering over the years i
receive regular monthly weekly sometimes
daily emails and calls from residents
regards the various levels of pollution
the site is just short a distance from
the of the canal from the residents of
altringham 20 metres from the houses in
fact
though many of these complaints were
around the light industrial processes on
site
many were also about the noise these
could range from tannoy announcements
employee shouting alarm signals from
reversing trucks radios blaring at three
am and much more many of these were open
air sources rather than the buildings
residents of course are praying that
these problems don't reoccur
however the committee reporter paragraph
161 states quite clearly
the site is significantly large and open
and is therefore difficult to contain
the noise in its current form yes the
new layout will break some of the noise
but we know despite all the measures
that cartwrights employed this had
little effect and residents said their
lives were continually blighted
the executive summary states the
application proposes 24-hour operation
seven days a week similar to the
previous unrestricted use of the site
therefore there can be no guarantee with
this application that residents will be
protected from reversing htv vehicles
alarms radio radio blare blaring open
and other open air activity during any
time through the day or night
referring to trafford's own policy
guidance in revised upd part one policy
e5 around hazardous and bad neighbor
industries it states it shouldn't bring
about a significant deterioration in the
quality of the environment of
surrounding areas
and in part two proposal e7 around main
industrial areas
the policy says
within the broad east industrial area
the council will permit development for
other uses only where these are of a
modest nature
well
this isn't modest
where other applications have
significant storage and distribution
purposes this committee has often
applied conditions that restrict
delivery
and pick up hours
it has even applied a probationary
period where if noise management plans
fail it can be brought back to this
committee
so why not here
the acoustic fence is unlikely to have
significant impact this was evident when
cut when cartwright's added it the site
is too open and the noise travels so so
far a distance from it
this site is to be led to units so
residents
or applicants may not know who will
occupy them and what impact will be for
some time to come
and in the committee report paragraph 77
the applicant says
365 days a year needed to make the site
and attract the end users who require
the flexibility of unrestricted hours of
operation
has this been questioned at all by the
planning team that will be an
interesting question to know
making the site fully operational 24
hours seven days a week means things
like lighting will be of critical
importance to residents and the nearby
ecology of the canal
however we are told at this stage no
details have been provided and this is
something that will be decided with the
local planning authority at a later
stage it seems worrying that residents
won't get sight of this
it is also a massive concern regards a
very important dark corridor along the
bridgewater canal
this is a home of several species of bat
and a site of biological importance
i would like to thank the applicant and
the lpa work for working hard on this
application to reduce the impact of
these issues i also welcome the
applicant's desire to work with
residents and be a good neighbour
however i would ask both of them to
think again on this unrestricted use
importantly i would ask you as commit
the committee to consider the real and
acute concerns of the residents
can 24 hour 7
365 days of unrestricted use on site
where noise can travel easily really be
justified
therefore i would ask you to consider
extra conditions or rejecting this
application until further consideration
can be given
thank you chair and thank you committee
thank you councillor jerome um
we have a statement i think from mr
greenbank to read it as well thank you
thank you chairman
this is a statement on behalf of mike
and karen
at green bank of hunterton way
our previous objections dated 27th of
september and the 19th of april 2022
still stand
we recognize that the site needs to be
redeveloped and are not against this in
principle what we are against and
objective in the strongest terms is the
use of the site for a haulage
distribution centre or hub being allowed
to operate 24 hours a day seven days a
week 365 days a year that means every
weekend bank holiday evening and day
time we will be hearing uncontrolled
commercial vehicle noise air brakes
reversing sirens loading unloading doors
banging opening closing forklift
maneuvering with sirens etc etc
we also strongly object to the site
being floodlight throughout all hours of
darkness as this would be like living
next to a stadium and ruin our
environment the ploy of asking for
unlimited site operational times allow
the developer to advertise free reign to
potential tenants and businesses with no
conditions and restraints and all that
brings to local residents
any removal of existing trees and
foliage to maximize usable site acreage
and footprint which will impact on our
outlook directly facing opposite across
the canal especially very tall
steel-clad buildings bordering along the
south side if granted this redevelopment
must have reduced operational hours that
don't include evenings weekends and bank
holidays thank you chair
thank you miss garlic mr winter do you
want to come up to the table with the
microphone there
just make sure the microphone is close
to you and if you just press the button
suddenly the light comes on and you'll
have um three minutes to speak to us
once you start talking thank you
thank you chair
we concur with the office report and
welcome the recommendation to grant
planning permission for employment
development on the site
the site when an established industrial
location allocated for employment uses
in the core strategy and was formally
occupied by cartwrights for every 50
years
the applicant network space is a
family-owned commercial property
developer and asset manager specialising
in the sma industrial sector and this
urban site is typical of the sites they
seek to focus on as a business
importantly they intend to properly
manage the units on the site once
occupied
the application pro proposals will
dramatically improve the quality and
type of accommodation retaining and
refurbishing a number of the outmoded
buildings and providing new sustainable
industrial units to meet the modern
demands of operators resulting
improvements across the site both
visually and operationally with
buildings which are soundproofed
network space will be investing 17
million in the construction of the site
and the proposals will deliver
significant economic benefits creating
around 380 jobs
we lost as a result which will be
provided and we'll go to meeting those
lost by the cartwright site this will
boost the local economy providing much
needed modern small and medium-sized
units to meet the strong current market
demand and shortage of light industrial
space in the area this is not a location
for a large distribution sensor as some
people have suggested and the site
configuration lends itself to sme
businesses and light industrial
occupiers
as the officer has highlighted in his
report the layout and configuration of
units on the site has been amended in
direct response to residents concerns
and the environmental health officer
who've expressed concerns regarding the
noise associated with the uses and the
impact on residential immunity we've
worked collaboratively with officers and
units have now been reconfigured on the
southern boundary of the site to create
an effective noise barrier to external
loading diaries and service yards
including a three metre high acoustic
fence on the southeastern boundary
there has been some concerns raised
regarding the 24 hour use of these
buildings this layout and the 24 hour
uses have been modelled as part of an
absolute worst case assessment in a
detailed noise report which has been
revisited and then could have detailed
following discussions with the council's
environmental health officer
confirms that the potential noise
emanating on the site when assess you're
in the daytime and nighttime periods
actually falls below the levels accepted
by national standards
given the type of occupiers these units
will attract these buildings are not
likely to be used continuously
throughout the night
given the lawful and historical use of
the cartwrights generated by significant
noise
generating significant noise concerns
with limited control this permission now
allows noise within these hours to be
controlled by the council to an
acceptable level
the hr has now satisfied this layout and
dealt with issues raised by residents
and local councillors expressed
previously
they've recommended a series of planning
conditions including measures to ensure
external plant and use of external
service areas are managed to fall within
acceptable noise levels the fact that
network space will manage these units
will also provide more control and noise
the officer report confirms there are no
other objections from any technical
consultaes including landscape and
ecologies offices and mitigation is now
in place for appropriate ready planning
conditions the applicant is now keen to
commence work on site with respect to
the request that you grant planning
commission today thank you thank you mr
winter
uh you'd like to return to your seat uh
and i'm now looking at for members of
the committee who would like to start
the debate councillor welton
oh or they could appeal against the
condition
as well
i'm sorry and of course uh you know and
of course
we welcome getting those jobs back
but as
councillor jerome told us
and he has done much work over the years
you know for residents across across the
way this site is very difficult in terms
of noise and
um for me for everything that is good
about this development
having a 24 hour
7
24 7
um
work
deliveries permitted is asking
for trouble that we will suffer from for
years we don't know who's going to go
into these units so i would
very much encourage the committee to ask
for a condition to be put on that
prohibits 24 hour 7. that
of course can be looked at further down
the line
and change depending on what the use of
those units is going to be
because this is the point when we have
the most control
over this application
later on it's going to be a lot more
difficult
anyway i'll be interested to hear what
everybody else has to say about that
thank you
councillor thomas
thank you chair
i'm reasonably in favor of this i think
it's
well thought through and taken into
account the officers uh discussions with
regards to the position of the larger
buildings which will act as a break wall
the only consistent the only the only
concern that i have is around the the 24
7 flood lifting for the lighting sorry
and i would suggest that alongside
condition 16
um all exterior lighting to be kept we
know it would spill i'd like that to be
capped at roof level then it won't spill
back over into the there's no
opportunity to go back over onto the
residences
um
in cancer jerome's and
councillor welton's uh discussion there
a lot has been made about the 24-7 the
the looks and the design of it suggests
to me
that it's not going to be
many of those units and as
the applicant stated it's smes that are
going to these buildings and these small
units and most smes are nine til six or
eight or six not withstanding the sun
may work a little bit after that so i'm
i'm in favor of uh
of the plans as i stand and i don't
think
the the proposed or the suggested sorry
um
effect on the residences on the other
side of the canal
um
will bear
the worry that they have so i'm quite
happy to propose that we accept the
officer's recommendation as is
thank you kevin summers cancer minis
okay so i think the redevelopment of the
science is absolutely necessary i quite
actually quite like a lot of the layout
of it
um they're the positive parts and the
only the only part the concern i have i
just think it's i don't think it's okay
for the the residents nearby to have
something um that's going to be creating
noise
um when you have families living nearby
that it can be 24 7. i don't think it's
going to be literally all day and night
but even disruptions in the night i
think is too much um to ask for i think
um
i think we do i i it's as is i'm i will
not be i'm not in favor i'm afraid i
would want some restrictions regarding
the times of day
more than necessarily which days of the
week as such but i want i would like a
time of day um restriction
um and i you know i'm not saying not
have access on the weekend i understand
the business is going to need access on
the weekend we do have shops that are
open
saturdays and sundays
so you know and things are going to need
to run um on the weekends as well but i
think that we need to look at a model
that will actually suit um the residents
nearby you don't we don't know who's
going to be in what unit and the unit
may well then change hands to another
user and i think we need to protect the
residents and we need to come up with
something that you know if if then the
use is changed later for individual
units then we can then look at what that
what is then presented to us then i
think that if we don't let we allow 24 7
whatever um
this could be really detrimental and our
our chance as councilor wilson said i
entirely agree our chance is now
to actually make to do the right thing
now rather than it going wrong having
having complaints you know
adversely affecting people's lives it's
not okay so and it is loss of
residential immunity so i will at the mo
as it is
not not in favor i'd be in favor of of
a conversation about a restriction of
times thank you and the lights to be
obviously low so that they're not going
to affect the neighbors nearby or you
know something with the lighting as well
thank
you uh councillor hassan
thank you jair uh
i am
absolutely fully supporting the offices
recommendations and my
colleague has said earlier
and i will ask
uh it is a good issue going to have a
380 more jobs and sustainable and
i mean we are going to generate more
revenue
local economy will grow the only
question how we can
i mean mitigate
24 7 i mean we need to consider the only
concern i have
we can we should put some condition
on on the transportations and the 24 7
issue this is the only concern otherwise
it's absolutely fine and fully agreed
with office's condition
thank you um
mr pearson i wonder if you want to
comment on um well the conditions that
have been suggested so one about the uh
the hours and days of use and um
and
well i suppose to what extent uh i know
we've sort of covered whether we could
change that condition but
i don't know if we have any idea as to
what would be a reasonable
sort of condition to choose whether
members need to set that out and then
also the
suggestion around the lighting which um
is condition 16 isn't it being capped at
roof level i think at the moment it says
capped at the horizontal so i'm just
wondering if you could just explain the
difference thank you
thank you sharon yes um
i mean
we have spoken to the applicants about
the the use the proposed 24 hour seven
years and we've we've asked them whether
or not they'd be prepared to
you know to restrict that use but their
response is that they need that
flexibility to attract uh occupants to
to the units and and to create
employment in an area you know broad
heath industrial park is one of the the
two main industry industrial or
employment sites in the borough um i'm
not sure we saw the slide area this is a
huge industrial estate and has been for
several hundred years
and so
you know we have to think whether or not
it's reasonable i think to to restrict
the the occupancy or the use of of
industrial units
when you know there's no evidence we
don't think to suggest that there will
be any harm caused by this scheme
we know i i suspect a lot of the
residents concerns um stem from the use
of the cuts cartwright site and that was
undoubtedly not a good neighbor
a noise abatement notice was served so
our
officers in in pollution and licensing
you know they they realized that was a
problem they served a noise abatement
notice but they've considered this
application uh very carefully and
discussed it with the applicant and
their view is that with the mitigation
proposed this should not cause a problem
for residents in terms of noise
um
there are several conditions as as you
will have seen in in the reports
um
you know in terms of trying to mitigate
uh the noise
um i'll just run through those now
just bear with me
um
so condition 13
talks about the units cd e1 and e2
so there's kind of mitigation in terms
of the construction of those buildings
to ensure that noise doesn't spill out
from those
condition 14
talks about all external fixed plan and
machinery
so a
kit that might be added subsequently to
the buildings so that's going to meet
certain noise criteria
and then condition 15
is the noise management plan
where we we seek to minimize the the
noise from
uh
well the whole site but generally sort
of movement within within within the
yards and as you've heard obviously the
the site layout has been changed such
that the buildings face the houses on
the southern boundary to try and um
mitigate that impact
so um
so i think our view as officers is quite
clear is that it would be unreasonable
to try and restrict the the the um
the operation you know in terms of the
timings the openings of these of these
industrial units and i think that's
likely to be quite a difficult exercise
in in any event it would require the
applicant coming to us i mean
we're granting we're looking to grant
planning permission from for a mix of
uses that would need to come back with
every
every applicant that came forward you'd
almost be looking at a personal
permission a lot of those uses might be
the same falling within the same use
class but they might just have slightly
different operating models it would
which might need to change in time to
suit the needs of the business it would
be extremely difficult to control that
and i think it would be very difficult
if we were to try and impose the
condition i think be very difficult to
enforce that as well
um you know something you can't suddenly
you've got to leave your your site of
employment a certain time of night and
you can't stay on if you suddenly need
to i don't know complete an order or
something
so have you given where it is had this
been a site in a different location you
know on a much smaller sort of
industrial site surrounded by houses
that would be very different
but on one of the boroughs two main
employment sites
we we think this scheme and this
recommendation with the conditions that
we have is
is appropriate
in terms of the lighting um i
acknowledge that lighting can cause a
problem both to residents and to ecology
particularly bearing in mind you know
the presence of the canal to the south
of the site
um
but
there is a condition condition 16
you know requires the submission of a
lighting scheme and we would look to
ensure that that lighting scheme had the
minimum impact on both residents and
ecology so we would consult the greater
manchester ecology unit and we would
consult our colleagues in pollution and
licensing to make sure that the lighting
um
didn't disrupt residents it isn't always
a case of keeping the height of the
lighting columns low
because then the light tends to spread
out further but
that can be looked at you know with the
submission of a scheme
i hope i've answered those questions
yeah yeah thank you mr pearson uh
councillor bunting
thank you chairman um yes i'm going to
agree with council thomas who spoke
previously uh you've proposed uh uh
offers yeah but we accept the report
without amendment uh and the
recommendation to grant therefore and
i'm more than happy to second to that
proposal
i think the
modified set layout and the way that
it's being amended uh in accordance with
this application
will improve the site i know people are
as mr piston points that may be haunted
by the memory of cartwright and the
various issues that were um surrounding
that site i know i've had various words
to say about cartwrights in the past at
this committee previously but we're not
revisiting that today uh i think at very
worst if we were to be ultra pessimistic
this would effectively be no worse than
previous if we're being more realistic i
think this is a significant improvement
on the previous situation as mr pearson
pointed out very clearly this is a main
industrial site it's not exactly
a back garden so we have to view it in
that light uh this is one of the two
main employment sites within within our
boat so i think given that scenario i
think it's entirely reasonable to have
24 hour operation especially given the
fact that it's always operated at 24
hours previously and the fact that they
cover fallback position as mentioned by
the officers previously that it could be
used for the same purpose as before
without the need for
further planning applications in terms
of the lighting as mr pearson points out
this this is also covered by conditions
and lowering them as he also pointed out
won't necessarily improve things because
it will simply improve light spread
whereas if lights are higher they tend
to spread spread to a lesser degree uh
well for baffling and what have you can
avoid that the uh lighting spills into
areas it's not intended to so the dark
corridor that uh the council points out
previously cancer uh jordan points out
previously won't necessarily be impacted
upon so i think generally speaking
overall this is a
we're constantly talking at this
committee about brownfield sites well
here we have a large brownfield site
here we have an opportunity to
regenerate a piece of land which was
used previously to make substantial
improvements to that area uh
as we do so to ensure significant
employment within this site and to see
its future for a remaining period of
time just one further point i would like
to make is in terms of the comment made
previously by council walton regarding
known uh occupiers known users unless we
were to try and make conditions
regarding uh
closure hours and what have you
personal to each individual unit and
change when each occupier uh changed
which is what you'd have to do if you're
going to go down that route which would
be extraordinarily complicated and
virtually impossible to enforce
uh you can't say well okay unit x is now
occupied by this given uh user we'll set
our
hours accordingly because of course that
could then shortly after change to a
different user and you're then gonna
have to start changing all the uh
times again so
overall for those reasons as i say more
than happy to second the proposal made
by council thomas previously and i look
forward to hearing what others have to
say thank you chairman
thank you councillor councillor and
stanley
i can be very brief because of echo all
the sentiments expressed by the previous
speaker it's uh i understand the
concerns of the neighbours that really
do cartwrights were
not a good neighbor to the people across
the canal
um
the developers here are not car rights
and it is an existing industrial site
it'll be redeveloped as a much more
modern industrial site
the the issues around um
noise and light uh pollution have been
well addressed in the report and are
will be controlled by a um a
conditions and also plans further to
come so i'll be very happy to
support the
the proposal as it currently stands
thank you chair
thank you councilman stanley um
councillor thomas she wanted to come
back in i think when you spoke the first
time you were happy to propose
uh approving
unchanged but you did also mention the
lighting i don't know if your concerns
have been delayed by what mr pearson has
said it might be useful to know
mainly i would just think on the
lighting the gates don't need to be
horizontal we need to be about 80
degrees from the square because if it
will shine it down if you're horizontal
you get more bleed
uh going over them because it allows the
light to to escape from the bottom we
all know light doesn't turn corners but
from 16 is fine it was just a suggestion
and similarly just what i would like to
add is regarding the noise from traffic
atlantic street is quite a distance away
from the canal and that's where the main
traffic noise will be coming from uh it
may be an idea as this moves along the
officers discuss a potential speed limit
on site which would reduce both traffic
noise and danger uh going forward it was
just a general
thought after mr pearson spoke
thank you council thomas councillor
welton you wanted to
to come back in um
you've you've heard that obviously
advice and other speakers around the
hours of operation i think if
we wanted to
add a condition around the hours of
operation we would need a a suggestion
as to what those hours should be so i
don't know if you want to touch on that
if you're still
minded to propose that
thank you councillor welton so um
councillor walton has moved that we that
we had a condition that delivery and
collection is limited to nine till six
i'm looking at moscow incredibly
restrictive okay
there are times when people
but but there is no technical evidence
of any harm arising from noise from this
proposal and the other thing to bear in
mind is the agent of change principle
this industrial estate was there first
and was there first
for
a couple of hundred years this is the
oldest industrial estate in europe if we
had wanted to protect the amenity of the
residents on the other side of the canal
then we should have imposed conditions
or refused planning permission for those
homes in that position not now seek to
try and restrict a very very long
established industrial area we we must
protect our industrial areas and allow
them to be economically active otherwise
we we will lose the benefit that they
bring we wouldn't we would never you
know if this this if this was in traffic
park and there are residences on the
other side of the canal to travel apart
we'd be saying exactly the same thing
shouldn't be restricting your industrial
areas in in this way
yeah so i i'll just and i've got a few
other speakers but i'll just say for my
for my own part that um
i think that is the issue isn't it the
housing on the other side of the canal
is is is new is newer than
the industrial activity and broad heath
and the people who bought those
properties would have would have known
that when they when they did um
and i do think um i mean i wouldn't i
wouldn't be in favor of a condition that
limited it till nine to six for the
risen pickup because i think that is i
think that is way too restrictive and i
think that
you know the economic growth opportunity
that's offered by this application and
the jobs that can be gained
i i can well see the agent's point that
if you had
the hours restricted in that way that
does limit the the marketability of
those of those units and i think
different units on the same you know you
could have adjoining units on the same
in the same industrial area applying for
different hours it would be impossible
to enforce so i for one i would be um
against that against that condition um
but i'll hear from um
uh councillor bunting i think you wanted
to come in again it was just to turn
thank you chairman just to reiterate a
point that was made early just because
your 24-hour operation permitted does
not mean you'll have 24-hour operation
permanently so it's not going to be like
unit e1 will never ever under any
circumstances close it will continually
work 24 hours a day 365 days forever
what it would mean is that the business
that was operated may work primarily
during the day occasionally as has been
pointed out through a major piece of
work comes in and they might have a week
when it's you know all hands to the pump
and it's working late for that period
although something's gone wrong an
emergency needs to be dealt with and it
means that someone's there at four in
the morning to to deal with whatever or
whatever it is that needs to be dealt
with a piece of machinery breaks down so
people have got to open the plant up get
it all fixed so that it can be up and
running in the morning that kind of
thing so that's far more likely than the
sort of
24 365 never closing the lights never
switch off everyone's always there you
know maximum noise at all times plus as
we've already seen from the uh
conditions there is significant
insulation within those
buildings on that site and noise
mitigation measures have been put in
place as mr pearson pointed out at some
length previously so just in terms of
the 24 hours yes that is the case plus i
very much agree with
the point it's one thing that's come up
over and over again you can't move next
door to something and then start
complaining about it a week after you've
moved it it just doesn't work like that
the industrial estate was there a hell
of a long time earlier than any houses
was it's just like if you move next to a
sports club and then start complaining
about the video
about about the noise from the sports
club well the sports was there a lot
longer a long time before you moved in
so it's a bit it is difficult agents of
change argument as has been pointed out
is another significant factor and as i
said also earlier this site has been
used 24 hours previously i know the
previous occupant was shall we say
sometimes more than a little difficult
but that doesn't necessarily this is not
cartwright on this application we cannot
continue to say well car twice did this
car twice did that car so i did the
other therefore began to refuse this
application this is a different
application we have to view this on its
merits i'm trying to
limit an industrial site like this to
six o'clock in the evening um there's a
can there's a condition i wouldn't like
to try and defend the appeal
thank you chairman thank you counselor
councillor walsh
thanks chair um
i think it's reasonable for the
committee to look at trying to protect
the residents council jerome spoke there
about the issues that have been raised
to win by car rise and it's clearly a
long history and the residents you know
i was looking at you
online today and there's lots of
residents have wrote him with genuine
concerns and i don't think it's wrong
for this committee to try and explore
that
um
i think what council bunting said just
at the end how could we defend it be
reasonable to put a condition but i
suspect and i'd be interested in our
legal advice could we defend putting the
condition on that say five days a week
half day on a saturday i don't think we
would i think our hands are tied that's
that's it
and and and and i would love to do that
protect the president to keep the to to
keep our applicant happy to keep the
people going to use the site and and
have jobs and to keep our residents
happy that's a reasonable way but i do
think our hands are tied
um
if there are problems with noise on the
site
will we'll take measures to do that
richard pollock sent a a reporting about
about the testing that he'd done about
the noise
so i think if there is an issue and
certainly uh the ultrasound counselors
will know about it then we move we move
quickly and mr winter the agent is
hearing these concerns i'm sure he'll
obviously to the ground and if they do
our problems do crop up they will deal
with it and and
and ask uh businesses or to take
measures to reduce the noise that
impacted on residents so i'm going to
support the application chair now it's
perfectly reasonable for this committee
to go around the houses if necessary no
pun intended to try and find a solution
but i think a hands attack they do say i
would like a legal view on that and if
there's a if there's a problem in the
future we've got our pollution team
we've got richard [ __ ] and they will
take steps to mitigate them and work has
been done on that it is a comprehensive
report so with that chair um i'll be
supporting the application thank you
thank you councillor walsh um i wonder
if we could have some uh legal advice on
the on the prospects of defending that
sort of condition thank you yes i mean
um
i would say that all the
planning um judgment has been put
forward at the meeting tonight and it's
absolutely clear that the
condition hasn't got evidence cogent
evidence to support it if it was put
forward
and and we would struggle probably at an
appeal to defend that
because it has to be reasonable
and necessary and enforceable and all
those things have been proved to be
difficult to do
so
i would support the planning
planning point of view on this
completely
it's yeah uh just uh i've been involved
in two appeal hearings not in trafford
in similar circumstances where um
stringent conditions were imposed um
contrary to an officer recommendation
for similar situations and indeed one
where residents were a lot closer than
this lost them both
[Music]
thank you miss curley council welcome is
at a new point you have spoken several
times
okay i think i think you've made the
point councillor welton you've moved
that we
uh limit the
times of delivery and collection from
the site from the whole site to
between nine and six is anyone willing
to second that proposal
i think would be acceptable because but
people do need to go to bed
hold on please counselor elton
councillor minister if you finish your
point yeah i'm saying
i understand that it's not you know that
the science has been there a long time i
get this but we do have now houses i'm
afraid i know it's not it's not to me
it's not a case of which came first the
chicken or the egg it's a case of these
both the neighbors are there and we need
to find a way i think um and this is our
opportunity to get it right and i think
to say that libras can happen with you
know lights on and everything going on
essentially in the dead of night i don't
think it's acceptable and that's a loss
of immediacy for the neighboring lessons
and it's not okay
so uh i don't i don't i don't i don't
think you know you're saying
obviously councilman it's okay you can't
submit a start point cancel minus that
point's been made what's the what's the
condition that you're proposing
officers aren't convinced that actually
the noise would be worse from that part
of the site because of the protection
from the unit but but you know
the proposals made by the council
minutes i think we need to know okay is
anyone willing to second council
amenities proposal of uh nine until
eight on the southern part of the site
[Music]
um you can but you've spoken several
times councillor welton so i'd like an
indication as to whether you're willing
to second cancel the minister's proposal
no i would like to propose another an
alternative thank you
anybody else looking to second council
amenities proposal
no okay uh councillor welton what's your
proposal i will propose from 12 until
five please
for
no deliveries to the units on the
southern side of the site c d e 1 and e
2. thank you can i clarify i'm assuming
that's 12 midnight or 5 a.m just just
but for the absolute avoidance yeah
trying to give some a little bit of
clear sleep time for the people
in the houses directly across from that
bit of the site
you have to second that
okay we'll vote on that motion and
motion is whether to add a condition
um
as proposed and seconded so that is to
limit the
uh hours of delivery and collections
um so that that's not uh not allowed
between twelve midnight and five in the
morning
um
you yeah i'm fairly odd to say this when
i counter diagonal so we'll vote first
of all in that motion whether to insert
that um
condition so um all those
in favor of that motion if you could
raise your hands now please
and all those against that motion
thank you councillor i think you said if
we
if we didn't agree that you'd move to
refuse is that
what's happening to you okay
on the basis of um
damage to residential immunity
okay so we'll vote on the motion for uh
refusing planning permission now
all those in favor of refusal you could
raise your hands
and all those against refusal please
[Music]
okay so that motion is not carried you
do need to take this
okay and we do need to uh finally have a
vote on
the um recommendation of offices which
is to is to grant planning permission so
we're voting now on whether it's a grant
planning permission so all those in
favor of that motion if you raise your
hands please
okay and all those against please
okay thank you so that motion is carried
and planning permission is granted for
that development
thank you
next application that we'll look at is
154 broadway in david hume application
107
207
[Music]
and for members of the committee that
starts on page 113 of the bundle that
you have
it's mr knowles with us this evening
thank you
okay so first of all we're going to have
a an introduction from mr day thank you
yeah thank you chair um
this application seeks planning
permission to change the use of the
property from a dwelling house
use class c3
to reuse the supported living
accommodation use class c2
for three children under the age of 18.
the application has been reported to the
planning and development management
committee as more than six objections
have been received conscientious
recommendation
i'll just put the
site location plan on the screen um
the post use would provide living
accommodation for children with
diagnosed learning disabilities
it's proposed to accommodate up to three
children with three to four non-resident
carers working on a shift basis
each child would have their own bedroom
and the fourth bedroom would provide
sleeping accommodation
for a staff member staying overnight
the submitted statement confirms that
there would be a minimum of two staff
members on site at all times
and that children would not be allowed
out of the home independently without a
member of staff
due to their special needs and
disabilities
the existing garage would be altered to
provide an internal office
and would retain a store to the front
there were no proposed external
alterations to the property
a total of 15 letters of objection from
12 residential properties have been
received in relation to this application
with one additional objection
subsequently being withdrawn
main objections are in relation to noise
and disturbance
increased traffic and parking
safety concerns
impact on privacy
the operation of the use and anti-social
behaviour
the lha has raised no objections and the
pollution and licensing team has also
raised no objections subject conditions
um just running through
the slides
you can see photographs of the property
um
there with
three parking spaces on the frontage
um
and google's street view image
showing that was the same
in 2014
photographs of the rear garden of the
property
and the side boundaries and elevations
of the property
and the site layout plan showing three
parking spaces
on the frontage um the elevations which
are unchanged
and the internal layout plan and the
main change being
the conversion of the garage into an
internal office and store
um officers consider that appropriately
worded conditions including restricting
the number of children
restricting the use to a care home for
children under 18 years of age
and operating in accordance with an
agreed operating plan
would satisfactorily mitigate any
potential immunity impacts from the
proposed use
officers therefore consider that the use
would be acceptable in terms of visual
immunity residential immunity
parking provision and highway safety and
is recommended that permission should be
granted subject to conditions
thank you chair
thank you mr day so we have a
statement to be uh read out now from uh
mr knowles i thank you
thank you chairman this is a statement
um on behalf of jonathan knowles of 14
presswood close
i just want to reaffirm my objection
primarily on the basis of fear of crime
the published proposal gives the strong
impression that there's a significant
chance that young offenders may be
housed at the subject property
government statistics state that 33 to
66 when released from formal detention
reoffend
government data also highlights
unregulated care homes are increasingly
prone to be targeted by county lines
gangs
clearly every child needs appropriate
care but the issue with this specific
property is its location close to three
primary schools a school crossing in a
park maximize the exposure of a
significant number of children to crime
that could cause harm it's simply the
most inappropriate location for a
business of this nature
i also know that the freehold was
acquired by the previous owners on an
informal basis rather than by
enfranchisement which doesn't ensure the
removal of all restricted covenants
there's nothing to on the portal to
suggest that the restriction to domestic
use only has actually been removed which
would render the application invalid
thank you
thank you miss coley councillor carter
do you want to uh come up to the
microphone
i'm sure you'll have been here before
just make sure the microphone's close to
you and um you'll have five minutes to
speak to us once you start talking thank
you
thank you councillor hartley and
planning committee um i don't think i
need to tell members what a much needed
facility this is in our borough
and
um i think i want um i want to start by
saying it's a lovely home i've been in
the home
and it's in a lovely area and
the family who are with us tonight have
bought the home because they're from
ernst and they wanted to bring up their
own family in amsterdam which has got
access to lovely parks lovely schools
and they want that for the children that
they will be looking after in this
facility as well
so it's really important to them that
they wanted
because they could have got a cheaper
house elsewhere in the borough you know
it's a really smart area of davidhill
there
but it was important that they kept it
in the local area
the family who are behind me are all
involved so the main applicant is a
teacher in one of our primary schools in
amsterdam
um and between them the sis her sister
is an advanced nurse practitioner
there's a police officer
and the odd one out here works in
construction and we've also got auntie
jean with us tonight and auntie jean
manages the children's home in chilton
and she has already put the children's
home on notice in charlton if this
application is successful that she will
manage it so she's very experienced
throughout the application they've kept
local councillors in the loop um
and
they've also engaged with our complex
needs team
and the children's commissioner who i
think a few weeks ago said we wish you
just open because as you know we have a
massive problem in this borough that we
haven't got enough facilities so we
spend millions sending children out of
borough
and we know for children evidently it's
best to be kept in their locality
um and um the commissioning team have
made a big
um
a big thing about it's better to place
children in settings that resemble homes
rather than
institutions
um
[Music]
so yeah my next point was about how much
we do spend on our replacements and that
includes the transport costs and those
are needs led's budget and they're
absolutely out of control
so that's why to have something in
erinston would be brilliant
i know there has been some
issues made around accessibility this
facility is for children with learning
difficulties and
primarily autism
adhd
and um
so i don't think as an authority we
would be placing any child that had
mobility issues in this setting because
it just probably wouldn't be appropriate
um
but the family have said that they are
willing to consider adding a lift if it
was needed they've been in touch with
the company who can install one in two
weeks
so but they also feel that having that
might also disadvantage other children
who might have visual impairments or
hypermobility issues so they want to
balance that inclusivity with the risk
for children
i think the neighbors have completely
misunderstood what this is and i was
getting emails from people saying it'll
be sex offenders or it'll be borstal or
and actually it's not it's going to be
our most vulnerable children
um and i i know miss coley made
reference to someone has withdrawn
and so i would ask the planning
committee can we approve this proposal
tonight
we're all corporate parents in this room
and we all want the best for our
children and i think this facility would
be a
you know brilliant for the children that
need it
thank you
thank you councillor carter
um looking to members of the committee
to start now uh councillor diagonal
we'll start with you thank you
um i just want to say how much to
welcome this um proposal i think it'd be
an absolute asset to trafford um i think
it's really heartwarming that people are
looking at creating not only a living
for themselves but a beautiful home and
caring circumstances for some of our
most vulnerable children um and i am
disappointed that the residents perhaps
misunderstand its nature
and of course
these are children living in a family
house and i and i hope and expect that
there will be no different to any
children living in that house and the
disturbance to neighbours will be just
similar to any children who move in so i
really well commit and i support it and
i would like to propose that we accept
the recommendation
thank you guys thank you councilman
i'd like to second that um yes
i'm hoping the neighbor um realizes
quite you know
what they've said and have a think about
it um i think that you know this is this
is absolutely how to care for um our
vulnerable children and it's the right
setting i mean you know
i saw this i thought i'm really happy to
see it um
so yeah more than happy to second your
proposal thank you
thank you councilman councillor thomas
yeah he called his brief i think an
absolutely superb
proposal um even even better to
the mention of uh should anybody with
mobility difficulties there is a
planning plan in place already to add a
stairlift
my mum lives on the corner she's not
complained about it she is 82 she'll
walk past that with a dog every day and
she'll have no fear because it will look
to all intents and purposes like a three
child
all teenagers perhaps family house
um i'm very disappointed in some of the
uh
submissions by residents regarding um
the fact that
children with learning difficulties with
do value their house in this day and age
i found that quite
disturbing from my point of view i'd
like that on the record but than that
i'll be fully supporting this
thank you councilwoman stanley
ah thank you chair um
yeah what he said it's a very it's a
brilliant idea it's uh to bring up um
children with learning learning
difficulties and in that very nice part
of um um it's a it's a great proposal i
was also disappointed by some of their
actions the neighbors one hopes they
just misunderstood what was being put in
the um
what the plans were it was me who raised
the issue of disabled accessibility
um i know there's been some
correspondence with officers this
afternoon
um
and i think what we've decided upon here
for the sake of getting things moving
quickly
is instead of putting conditioning where
we're going to ask you to put a sterling
straight away we'll put a note in the um
in the note that you'll receive if we do
grant permission tonight which will just
ask you to respect the
your duties under the equalities act if
a dis if a physically disabled child
is allocated to the facility
but yeah it's a great great proposal
more than happy to support it provided
we can think
yep perfect brilliant thank you
thank you a councillor proctor
thank you chair
39 years ago the health authority
locally bought bungalow on spendythorn
road
um to house three adults with profound
learning disabilities
i was horrified to read in the then
stretford and nermson journal comments
from the neighbours
39 years on i was reading the same sort
of comments
that i i just don't understand
um a child with autism is no different
to a child without
autism they've got other needs but
they're still a child
and
yeah i'm shocked
i fully support this application i think
it'll be wonderful for
our children in trafford thank you
thank you councillor i mean yeah for my
part i'm also fully supportive i won't
repeat what other people have said but
i do think that you know the public
sector equality duty requires us to
advance equality of opportunity for for
those with a protected characteristic
um as compared to those without and that
includes disability and that includes
access to housing so i think as a
council we have positive duty to
advance housing rights and accommodation
rights particularly for children
um to to children with a disability
which is what this scheme proposes and
as councilor carter said we do have a
huge shortage of
supported assisted living places for
children so i uh wholeheartedly welcome
the application it's been um it has been
moved and seconded that we uh that we
agree with the office of recommendation
to grant permission
um so i suggest we move to vote no one
else is indicating they wish to speak so
uh all those in favor of uh granting
planning permission
that is unanimous thank you everybody
so that application is approved thank
you for everyone who came to speak on
that item
[Music]
the third application we'll look at is
at the
former westwood food stores on warburton
lane in partington
members of the committee that's on uh
starts on page is page one of your
bundle
and we will have an introduction from mr
day
yeah thank you chair um
so outline permission is sought in this
application for the erection of six
dwelling houses
with all matters reserved
so that means details of access
appearance
landscaping layout and scale would all
need to be submitted in a further
reserved matters application
and the application has been reported to
the planning and development management
committee as six objections have been
received
contra to officer recommendation
the application relates to a plot of
land situated between properties
the front onto warburton lane
chapel lane and there being a close
respectively
access to the site would be from
warburton lane to the west
and there are several commercial units
located to the west with the area
otherwise being residential in character
the site is currently unused with a
number of mature trees and shrubs to its
boundaries
the application has been amended to
reduce the proposed number of
properties from eight to six in the
interests of residential and visual
immunity
and indicative plans have been submitted
showing potential site layouts
and elevations with the six dwellings
laid out as three pairs of semi-detached
properties
with parking provided to the front of
the drawings
however as the application is in outline
form with all matters reserved these
details would not be approved at this
stage
letters of objection have been received
from the occupiers of five neighbouring
properties
and from parsington parish council
concerns relate to
sorry and and also
the positive partington partnership um
concerns relate to access local loss of
privacy
visual intrusion impact on local
services contaminated land drainage
trees and ecology
um so there you can see the indicative
um plans
the inductive site layout showing the um
six drawings
proposed inter in relation
to three pairs of semi-detached
properties
with parking provided
to the frontage and access
from warburton lane
and the indicative elevation drawings
and layout plans
um officers consider that the indicative
plans demonstrate that the site could
accommodate six dwellings
of an acceptable design
without having an undue impact on the
residential community of neighbouring
properties
and whilst providing an acceptable level
of amenity for future occupiers
the agent has demonstrated that the
existing access would be acceptable in
highway safety terms
and in terms of ecology trees drainage
and contaminated land the relevant
consultees raise no objections subject
to conditions
the tilted balance in mppf program 11 is
engaged due to the application being for
residential development and the council
not having a five-year
supply of housing land
in terms of benefits the development
would provide six additional dwellings
and a small economic benefit during the
construction phase
officers consider the proposal accords
with the development plan
and that there were no adverse impacts
that would significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits of
granting permission
it's therefore recommended that
permission is granted subject conditions
sorry just i haven't shown the
photographs there that shows the access
um
from warburton lane
and photographs of the application site
and that that photograph shows the
closest
property at six for being a close um
with a conservatory that would be facing
the proposed development
thank you chair
thank you mr day um is it as i think we
have a statement from mr spooner this is
a statement thank you chairman this is a
statement read on behalf of paul spooner
of wayside chapel lane
i put forward this correspondence for
the committee meeting as i understand
none of the affected residents can
attend the meeting in person
a number of representations letter
online have been made previously during
august to september 2021 this
correspondence is to reinforce those
concerns and objections in line with
council planning issues
format for focusing on forecast key
aspects pollution including flooding
loss of privacy noise design and
appearance firstly pollution that exists
today and in the past
significant waste including from the
westwood garage has languished over
years above ground and then during 2020
buried underground within the site by
large diggers photographic evidence is
available witnessed personally by number
six verbena
this waste burial was followed by during
2020 by flooded flooding with
contaminated water in various verbena
close houses and gardens 678 registered
this and here at wayside and our
neighbour at 28 chapel lane
this was also accompanied by an
infestation of rats on the chapel lane
houses today after heavy rain this can
still occur
japanese knotweed is also prevalent
behind the garage on the said land and
has been spreading to at least one
neighbouring garden
asbestos is also potentially hidden
underground for many years back when the
land was used as a brace girdle coach
garage
the concern is that by building a
substantial number of houses this will
cause significant generation of toxic
circumstances in the location and
neighbors in addition it will
potentially affect the said houses
themselves
secondly loss of privacy and tree
protection all neighbor residents are
highly concerned for the protection
conservation of boundary trees and
bushes and their good support for co2
reduction
these boundary trees and shrubs provide
some level of privacy
however for wayside which will back onto
all six houses the build design and
appearance will lead to increased noise
and reduced privacy irrespective of
trees and especially during austin and
winter when leaves disappear and trees
are bare thank you
thank you miss carly any members looking
to speak on this application
uh councillor walter
that was the that was the statement it
was just it was just a statement yeah
sorry yeah um councilmembers
um mine's a question really so the um
the concern obviously raised by the
neighbor about um the japanese knotweed
um will it be removed
that was my question and then obviously
if they do dig up stuff and you know um
it's a i'm assuming that we have a
condition that if they dig up
asbestos or whatever the hell they find
when they dig it
that they'll remove that safely as well
but will the japanese not weed from from
the area be removed with this
yes so a condition is proposed condition
number nine um which relates to a
japanese knotweed
control and eradication
method statement so
yeah that would require them to submit
details of how they're going to do that
and then obviously implement
um is and is that too like where it's
obviously spread into i know obviously
so i understood that on the condition on
the sites where it is but where it's
then gone from that site and spread into
um
neighboring you know areas and enabling
neighboring plots but it would it also
be removed from there because if it's
come from
that plot i just want how are we going
to get rid of it all we have no evidence
where it started council ministers okay
okay
right it hasn't okay we don't know that
it's coming from there we
don't
okay
thank you uh mr um
counselor
take him back to school though thank you
um
it just seems to me that that
the plan
going forward would would to me seem
like an improvement on what seems like a
fairly unpleasant brownfield site and as
such i'm happy to support the
recommendation that it goes ahead i hope
um
at the end of all this neighbours
appreciate um that actually it should be
a happier and healthier site
sitting right behind the houses and what
seems like a bit of a
um
ogre swamp at the moment i don't know if
that's a technical planning term but it
seems to me what it would best be
described as so i think it seems like a
good idea and i'm happy to propose that
we accept the recommendation to her
thank you councillor no cancer akinola
um i'd like to second that because i
think it's a very good use of the site
and bearing in mind what is already
there i don't think it will be any more
denser than
what's very close by
um so it's a good use we'll have six
more houses which are desperately needed
thank you uh councillor welton
yeah um i agree with those uh those
points that have been made i think it's
great that they've reduced the density i
think it would have been an issue if
they've been eight that six is much more
appropriate in that location uh those
roofs look really ripe for solar panels
so hopefully when this comes through for
um for uh you know full planning
permission then then then they'll be
have pla a good array i believe is the
word
uh counselor welsh
chet um
just talking about the roof's chair i
just wondered about the properties
nearby um
the land is raised here isn't it it
falls away to the to the close that's
nearby
are the houses the heights of the houses
with those
can i say punchy roofs just you know
compatible with the properties around it
will they stand out um
um i so i think it's that that's a
reserved matter as it was today so the
the the applications outlined to
um develop six houses in principle but
the height and the exact design of the
houses will be something at the reserve
matter stage is that right yes so all of
the details you see on that plan when
we're not we're not approving those
details
if you approve the application tonight
you're not actually approving those
details you're just approving the
principle
of um
six dwellings on the site obviously this
this
these details have been submitted um
to um show that there is potential to
put six dwellings on the site and it may
be that um a scheme that comes back at
reserve matter stages is similar or or
possibly even identical to this but at
the moment
the approval of the application tonight
wouldn't actually be approving these
details so it wouldn't approve
that precise design
of property and those matters could be
considered further within it was a
matters application in you know in terms
of
the actual um the actual level of the
houses and the actual design of the
houses
council thanks jen that that extends to
the balconies that's what the issue that
people in chapel have got concerned
about 34
meters away and that
there could be balconies at reserve
matters and there couldn't be balconies
that reserve matters that's the issue
isn't it yeah it's a matter that could
be considered further
in the reserve matters application it
wouldn't be
approving this application tonight
wouldn't um
grant any
any approval specifically for balcony's
name
okay uh
no another member's looking to speak
it's been moved and seconded that we
uh agree with the office of
recommendation to grant planning
permission so we'll vote on
that motion so all those in favor of
approval please
and that is unanimous thank you
everybody
so that's um
so we'll move on now to the uh last
application for permission to develop
which is the uh pelican in
application 105 786
and that's on uh page 73 of the bundle
and we'll have an introduction from ms
curley
thank you
the application before members this
evening relates to the pelican inn
public house and ultragum lodge hotel uh
situated adjacent to the a56 in
temporary
this application seeks full planning
permission for the demolition of all
buildings within the site and their
replacement with an apartment building
containing 22 residential units and a
care home with 75 beds the proposal also
includes a new access point from the a56
car parking provision and associated
landscaping and amenity space the
applicant has lodged an appeal against
the council's non-determination of this
planning application
so members are not able to determine the
application this evening
however you're being asked to consider
how you would have defined the
determine the application if you've been
able to do so
so that we can define our position at
the subsequent appeal
i'd like to just draw members attention
to the additional information report if
i may because there's some some
information in there which i think you
need to be aware of if you just bear
with me i'll turn that up
and it
largely relates to an assessment of the
need of the care home uh and its impacts
and comments from the trafford ccg
um and the council's adult social care
service um
both groups have raised concerns um but
they in a number of respects but broadly
divided into three categories and the
firstly the need for a care home of this
type in the location the financial
impact on the council and the ccg
associated with the with the development
and the impact of the development on gps
um
so in terms of the the need
we've been advised by adult social care
that that although there's a there's a
there's a need for specialist elderly
accommodation and there is an oversupply
of um general needs accommodation even
with some lower level dementia carers as
this as this facility would would
propose there are 288 vacancies in care
homes across across trafford
um
and and it's effectively not not the
sort of specialist care that that we re
that is required by the council
uh however in planning terms um
any care beds
um of this nature c2 residential care do
count as housing land supply in the
widest sense so they count in the same
way as uh normal
market market housing would do albeit
there's an offset so 75 care beds
equates to a prop to 41 dwellings and so
we still have to take into account the
benefit that actually a housing um
supply
would would would have
in terms of the financial impact on the
council of ccg this is related to the
fact that once um
self-funders in these in these homes
when when they can no longer afford to
their own care that burden then falls
onto the council um and that's a cost
and i raise that so you're aware of it
but also to to
make it plain to members that that isn't
something that this planning committee
can consider so the fact that a land use
has a financial impact on the council
is not um it is not material and there's
this case law that has established that
um but there's also an impact on the
development on gp practices now that
is a land use um so that's a that's an
impact a social impact on on services so
so like an impact on on educational open
space or something like that and that is
something that that we can take into
account
um
so
in conclusion when we're looking at that
we've we've
offices have concluded there's a benefit
associated with the contribution made
towards the council's housing land
supply and the potential associated
freeing up of local housing but it's
significantly tempered by the fact that
there's a need for this facility of this
type hasn't been demonstrated
by the applicant an information provided
by
council's adult social care service
indicates there's not a need for such a
facility in terms of the impact on gps
um
in terms of mitigation
if the application was otherwise
acceptable we would be asking for a
contribution of 900 000 pounds in order
to
effectively fund an additional gp for
five years now that's that's a
significant contribution
but the ccgs reasoning for that and the
reason we consider this is reasonably um
connected to the development is that um
that is how much it will cost
to bring in an additional gp
in into a surgery and if you don't bring
in an additional gp there's no
mitigation so you can't bring in half a
gp or um
you have to have enough money to to to
provide that
um
so so that's fundamentally what what the
ccg are are saying but that and that
doesn't tip the balance um as far as
we're concerned what um
anymore in
in in favor of of of the application
in terms of in terms of other issues
uh the proposal would result in the
total loss of an undesignated heritage
asset
and there'd be the loss of a community
facility without appropriate
justification
furthermore the proposal would fail to
deliver a policy compliant level of
affordable housing the case which is not
supported by a viability appraisal
the proposed development is also
considered to be out of character with
the urban grain of the surrounding area
visually intrusive in the street scene
and will represent over development of
the site by reason of its layout height
scale massing and design
in addition the development is not
considered to provide a good standard of
amenity for future residents due to a
lack of appropriate outdoor private and
shared immunity space and a shortfall
with most departments from the
nationally described space standards
um
the tilted balance is um applied because
it's a residential scheme and we do not
have a five-year housing land supply
but weighing the benefits of the scheme
against the harm including those in the
additional information report we have
concluded the adverse impacts of
granting planning permission would
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits of doing so
now the chairman asked me earlier if i
would
explain a little bit more about vacant
building credit uh which i which i will
now now do um vacant building credit is
is government policy and it's set out um
in detail in the
in the national planning practice
guidance effectively what what it
says
is that um
council should should consider
and
and are not absolutely obliged to
offsetting vacant buildings on
brownfield sites against the overall
affordable housing requirement on on a
on a site and if you just bear me with
me i'm just going to refer to some to
the guidance
myself so i can explain this properly
so
effectively a credit is should be
applied which is the equivalent to the
gross floor space of any relevant vacant
buildings being brought back into use or
demolished as part of the scheme and
deducted from the overall affordable
housing contribution
but
um the va but each case is a matter for
the collecting authority to judge the
policies intended to incentivize
brownfield development including the
reuse or redevelopment of empty and
redundant buildings
and considering how the vacant building
credits should apply local planning
authorities should have regard to the
intention of national policy and in
doing so it may be appropriate for
authorities to consider whether the
building's been made vacant for the sole
purposes of redevelopment and whether
the building is covered by an extent or
recently expired planning position for
the same or substantially the same
development obviously the second of
those bullet points doesn't apply here
but the first but the first does
um and it is its office's view that the
building has been made vacant for the
sole purpose of redevelopment the site
was marketed as a redevelopment
opportunity we've seen that material
um
we've also had had regards as it says
local planning authorities have regards
the intention of national policy and
it's intended to incentivize brownfield
redevelopment
we know full well there is no need to
incentivize this there were over 600
bids for this site
so you know so somebody is going to
bring somebody will bring this forward
this this
um so
in this case we don't think that uh that
vacant building credit applies
and thus
in the absence of any viability
appraisals suggest there should be a
lower level of affordable housing and
knowing what we know about viability in
the borough at the moment with our
recent appeal decisions we think that
the amount of affordable housing on this
site should be 45 percent thank you
thank you miss coley there's no speakers
on this item so uh just looking to
members of the committee now who wants
to speak councillor talking
uh thank you can can i just ask for the
benefit of the committee i mean is there
a particular reason it hasn't been
determined and it's now gone to appeal
because we were
talking to the applicant about an
alternative scheme we put a number of
alternatives to them
but they they say that their land deal
required them to appeal in order to hold
on to the to the site and and so and so
they did i would have liked to have
brought a different scheme to this
committee for approval i really would
have done
thank you i just wanted i thought that
would just be beneficial just explaining
it that's all um
i'm actually really disappointed by this
proposal uh it's
an intensification of the site the way
to way too many houses housing dwelling
units on here um
it's
not
as a design i don't like it it's it's
not a nice nice design it doesn't it's
not sympathetic to what was what is
there currently
um i completely agree with officers uh
the officer's report that um
where it states that the building has
been looked after they could have done a
lot more they could have done more with
the design the
external immunity space that they're
proposing isn't adequate enough
so i'm trying to get this brief the the
the northern bits um which has been left
are proposed to be left as the main
immediate space for the flats and um
principally that just looks like a
mosque to me uh it's it's gonna get it's
gonna overgrown it's gonna get it's it's
ninja it's not gonna be nice i just
think it's a really disappointing design
uh uh proposal overall
not saying i don't agree disagree with
the idea of having houses or or even
potentially care home if there could be
a viability assessment that says there
needs to be one there
just this is way too big way too intense
and it's like i say it's not going to do
anybody any favors
i'll leave to that
thank you councillor chalking uh
councillor
thomas
thank you chad just bro i probably again
agree with council charlton and i think
the officer's report is
concise and to the point and
i for one don't want to be somebody
selling a committee that loses this
historic building to
something not that is not
suitable for the site
so i'll just just to cover off what
council tolkien said uh if he didn't i'm
happy to propose we accept the officer's
recommendation
thank you council thomas are you happy
to section that position
thank you chairman um i agree with some
aspects of the photo and said yes this
design is
again shockingly awful but then again
how many times have we seen recently
care home designs come before us that
are shockingly awful i think i've
commented on a few of them in various
tones previously we usually end up with
a second application materializing out
of the woodwork at the next application
next meeting or two
where i mean i have said on various
occasions it's a pity didn't bring that
round the first time you know you've
wasted our time
with your ridiculous application and you
obviously had this one in the background
because it's come forward so quickly you
couldn't possibly have come up with it
from scratch in the meantime but here we
are again another large ugly building um
in terms of the loss of the uh heritage
asset and perhaps maybe less
uh concerned uh
that building is essentially built as
what it is and it's anyone who's been
anywhere near it in recent it's been
failing
for some time uh you know if you've got
another more than half a dozen people in
it if you ever go anywhere near the
place so the idea that it's going to be
viable as a public house in that format
uh and the
accommodation blocks behind i've been
dead for donkeys years as long as i've
lived in traffic i can't remember those
things being used so in terms of the
actual over development i agree
wholeheartedly in terms of the actual uh
design uh and the uh the look of the
thing uh
i i i concur in terms of the loss of
this much loved asset uh i am perhaps
less
uh less in agreement because i don't
know it's uh my colleague councillor
holden often says the best way to turn
an unwanted monstrosity into a much
loved asset is to threaten to close it
um
so
you know
it's always the case so
uh yeah although i'm more than happy to
go along with the officer
recommendations refuse i think the uh
waxing lyrical about what a wonderful
heritage asset this is is perhaps an
argument that is on
shaky ground at best thank you chairman
thank you councilman kent hello minis
well um
so so i mean about it being it is a
non-designated heritage asset it is uh
was it whether you like the look of the
building down
or not is it and the beauty is in the
eye of the beholder it is in the
landmark on on the road um when i turn
left onto park road it is what i look
out for so it is
you know and and i i've been in the
pelican when it was
nicely thriving uh for for a pub quiz so
i disagree that it can't be brought back
um to be a pub i think it does require
tlc the building and i think that's i
personally think that that is the right
way for it to go
um i think that knocking it down and
building a monstrosity is not the way to
go um it's enormous um the sheer scale
of it you just think oh my god um that's
not the way to go um i think all i mean
you know i think all the the report
action when and ms coley's explained it
to us i think is extremely comprehensive
explains exactly why
this is an absolute no goer and i
absolutely has it been it's been
proposed exactly that i will be i'll be
i'm more than happy to say yes i would
have refused this had it come
in
its current state as a live application
thank you thank you councilman uh
councillor stanley
uh to pick up on uh councillor bunton's
point i will wax lyrical about this
building i think it's i think it's a
lovely building it's a classic example
of a 1930s juda beat beaten motoring pub
it's fantastic
but the scheme itself
uh if we were going to knock down this
much loved asset it would have to be for
something massively different to the
schematic in front of us because for all
the reasons laid out in this initial
report and in the additional information
pack
this is not the right scope so
happy to very happy to support the
officer's recommendation on this one
thank you chair
thank you councillor
well it's been said now but i was also
going to defend the pelican which
perhaps i've mentioned previously i am
quite fond of um
i i think
it represents the
vernacular architecture of the area
which is 1930s
you know as councilwoman celine says
you know generally chewed a beat and it
has that um
sort of
bucolic aspiration that it might be a
tudor hall out in a meadow somewhere
which might seem ridiculous now it's
sitting at the side of the age 86
but
it is a landmark it is part of the area
um
i'm not much of a pub goer myself but we
are now lacking in a public house there
is nothing
really walkable to and and those places
do offer
a community space for a lot of otherwise
lonely people so you know it's not
something that i would see go happily
i'm not i'm not entirely sure this is
the place to suggest that it was
deliberately run down but i do know that
that um
uh community groups that were
initially hosted there in the building
were were asked to leave some time
before
um which which left you know probably
took away a small amount of takings for
them i know my mum's knitting group was
there and so that was 12 small sherries
down a week when they shut that down
so you know it is
it might not be loved by everybody but
it is loved by a lot of people um
so
um i would quite like to see it stay and
i completely support
the officer's recommendations on this
what's this the buildings that are
suggested to be substituted for it
um
have no appeal at all and especially if
they are unnecessary then i don't think
that that's the way for it to go so i i
would like to support their officers
recommendations with this
thank you councillor dagnol i mean i
agree with other speakers i won't repeat
what um
what's been what's been said i mean what
really concerns me is the non-compliant
level of affordable housing there's no
justification uh offered for that and
you know the residential amenity is
going to be really poor for the for the
occupiers of the
uh apartments i mean there are a couple
of what i thought were positive points
but they've evaporated in the light of
the additional information that we've
had and one was that the apartments
would be accessible and adaptable but i
think 14 out of the 22
apartments are below the nationally
described space standards which i know
is not um
is not part of our development plan but
i think it's still an indication as to
what a poor level of residential
immunity a lot of these apartments will
have so it's no good making them
accessible and adaptable if they're tiny
once you get in there um and uh and the
other one which on on the face of it
looked attractive was was providing the
care home provision but i think the
information we've had from the
uh ccg and adult social care is pretty
clear that we
we don't need this uh extra capacity um
and and so i think both of those
possible positives do do evaporate i'd
i'd like to see the the pub building uh
remain i'm not convinced it has a
future as a pub but i know it hasn't
been marketed in that way um but even so
it can't continue to be a pub i do think
the the site could be developed and and
that asset could be could be preserved
um so uh no other members looking to
speak it's been moved and seconded that
we
uh agreed with the office of
recommendation that excuse me we will be
minded to
refuse permission so uh all those in
favor of that resolution please raise
your hands
and that is unanimous so that resolution
is uh approved and we've demanded to
refuse
[Music]
okay so that's the end of that
application that's the end of section
10. we're going to move on now to
agenda item 11 which is an update on the
uh appeal by uh acre manchester limited
in relation to uh city point 701 chester
road to hornby road
there is a report in the agenda pack um
we'll have an introduction from miss
curley
thank you thank you chairman um this is
a report to provide an update to members
uh in respect of the appeal submitted by
manchester um after the refusal of the
hotel scheme at um city point in the at
the march meeting and several of you i
know
we're at that meeting um
since the decision of the committee in
march the layout plans have been
reviewed again with the local highway
authority and there's been concerns
raised about a statement that the
proposed drop-off and pickup point on
warwick road would result in an
unacceptable loss of pedestrian footway
to the detriment of pedestrian safety
this is factually inaccurate and may
have resulted from a misunderstanding of
the plans displayed at the committee
meeting which showed a clear two meter
wide footweight partly set into the site
and an area for adoption by the local
highway authority
um as such officers are seeking
authorisation to remove this sentence
from the highways reason for refusal due
to concerns uh over the potential for
the council to have deemed to have acted
unreasonably in this regard uh and also
draw
members attention to um paragraph 14
which opens the door for members to
reconsider any of the other reasons for
refusal um that
that they may uh that they may wish to
in
in light of legal advice that we've had
thank you chair
thank you miss curley um
councillor bontig i will i will come to
you first i'd i'd like to propose that
we maybe deal with this in two stages
because i think the
having read the report i think the
um proposal to
remove the reason about the payment is
pretty uncontroversial i don't know if
anyone disagrees with me on on that view
if anyone wants to to argue that we
should keep that reason for refusal then
i think it would be good to clear that
up and and and withdraw that reason um
council thomas you want to
briefly
the plans at the meeting weren't as
clear as the plans were going in front
of us
um
councillor bunting did you want to
comment on on that particular
reason so
i i think that's the main resolution
we've been asked for and we will come on
to the other factors so
uh if if members are happy i'm going to
suggest we vote on that resolution to
agree with the recommendation that we
withdraw the reason
for refusal around the pavement width
which which is not going to be reduced
so
members in favor of that resolution if
you could indicate no please
so that is
that is unanimous okay so that that
reason is is um withdrawn uh which i
think is helpful and then the second
stage was to was to
consider the other um
the other reasons that were advanced for
refusal um
and i know um members will have seen the
advice from council about the the merits
of defending the
appeal so um
uh councillor bunting i'll come to you
now that's okay
thank you chairman just before i do come
to this just i would like to agree with
the comment made previously by council
thomas
the
details we've got here regarding the
payment are significantly uh better than
the details we had at the time if we'd
had that layout and makes details we've
got we maybe that wouldn't have been
included in the first place um
i think if i remember correctly i had
more than one or two words to say about
this application at the time but i think
the pavement was about the only thing
that i didn't criticize um i
wish to make it clear i'd stand by
every single word i had to say
that application i said what i meant
and that meant what i said um
it was an apparent design i disagreed
with every last aspect of it and so did
anyone who lived anywhere near the damn
thing as far as i could see
um and whilst i am happy to go along
with the removal of that sentence
uh i stand by my comments that i made at
the committee and i uh would say them
all again if we were to repeat the
application thank you chairman
thank you for making your position clear
council hunting um
council thomas will come to you what i
was going to suggest is another motion
that um
so my own view is that we we
we should look at this again and we
should look at the other reasons for
refusal because of the advice that we've
had i appreciate kendra bunting wouldn't
be minded to change his mind at the
moment on that but i think
um given the advice we've had and the
risk of
costs being being awarded against the
council
um i do think we need to look at the
reasons that are advanced for refusal
and whether we whether we stand by those
obviously the decision notice has been
issued so
um the effect of the effect of
discussing that and withdrawing any
any reasons for refusal will be the
impact will be on the appeal so it would
be withdrawing
certain grounds for opposing the appeal
or withdrawing all the grants for
opposing the appeal possibly so
i think in all if we if if members agree
that they want to have that discussion
then um
i suppose what we don't have the benefit
of here is is the full report that we
saw first time around and some members
of the committee weren't on the
committee at that point um so i dug it
out from the pile of papers
in my spare room to see but i think um
you know it was a difficult application
to to sort of discuss so
my own view is if if
members agree that we should have a
discussion about whether to withdraw any
of the other reasons for refusal that we
we bring that back uh to the next
meeting so that will give officers time
to prepare an updated report on the
application and then certainly members
who are not familiar can can be more
informed about it and we can have an
informed discussion on whether
we do want to withdraw any of the
further reasons for refusal so um
council thomas i'll come to you what
perhaps your members think about whether
they
would be minded to agree with my
suggestion thank you
yeah um it takes away what i was going
to say because i would agree with that
he needs to come back
um
of a mind similar to i think i seconded
it or proposed at the time
uh i'm of the same mind but i'm more
than happy to look at your fresh eyes i
don't think i'll change my mind but i
think i would be grateful if it does
come back
any other comments on
on that proposal cancer welton
[Laughter]
next opportunity for us to have a full
discussion i think any other members
looking to counsel the bond yes jim i i
simply disagree i think we spent a great
deal of time on this application
previously it wasn't a five-minute
conversation that this planning
committee previously it was a a very
lengthy drawn out discussion we've spent
a great deal of time on it if it does
come back again i will obviously try to
do it with franchise i will try to
be as professional as i can
but my opinion was a strong opinion last
time i said exactly what i thought and i
don't apologize in any way for saying
what i had to say uh i will i like
cancer thomas i
can't think of specific reasons off the
top of my head that might cause me to
change my mind but if such reasons
miraculously appear then i will then i
will take them into account but i would
say we have spent a great deal of time
it was a lengthy debate that we had
significantly
and i don't believe that is necessarily
going to generate a different result i
don't think it will necessarily benefit
any of the people of trafford to simply
waste time repeating ourselves from the
conversation we've already had although
i do accept that there were different
members of this committee
uh although
how many more applications will you also
have at that next one are we going to be
the lengthy agenda
is it going to be well there's nothing
else on the genders we might as well
follow with this
um okay we've already done it to death
point check i can't stand me
i also voted against this last time that
however there are new information come
to light when i read the uh the report
from council and gave me paul's thoughts
i don't know if i will change my mind
but i'd like to have the opportunity to
look at this again in the light of new
information
the
the real reason why we should spend more
time on this is the very
very possibility or what the possibility
to raise by council that if we go ahead
with this and we lose the bill costs
will be awarded so i think we always
think to the residents of trafford
to do with this
new information
all i was going gonna ask was that um
because this has come before us before
is it possible for the reports to be
sent a little bit earlier so we can ask
any questions so we can stay discussed
sometimes we can get a bit repetitive
and say what somebody else has already
said and ask those similar questions
yeah i mean you can you can go back to
the original report any time and we can
we can send links links to those because
obviously the original
um an appeal decision is material as as
well so we will be we will be referring
to those that that's fine
together in the in the format which will
be
about the um reasonableness of the
reasons for refusal as opposed to
strictly the merits of the case if that
makes sense
because
some of the bits of the paper that i got
and i read
and i'm not quite understanding a bit
about it's not precedence but because
they put in an application they made
reference to our application i've been
doing in 2020 and
i didn't understand how the relevance of
that so if it was a little note you
could just tell me
why that makes a difference
yeah yes certainly um previous
applications and inspectors decisions
are material
and um where
where an inspector or the secretary of
state has made a decision in relation to
a planning application
um and then
members effectively seek to
uh or the council as a whole officers as
well speak to almost overturn that
decision by coming to a different view
that is
generally
deemed unreasonable behavior because
that inspector's decision should carry
significant weight in members
consideration of any future proposals
um
more indeed than than um
than almost anything other than
obviously the development plan but then
if the inspector has found that
something is development plan but there
are good material considerations that
would that would carry
more weight to disregard that
particularly when the proposal is
similar it
just
does carry significant risk of being
considered unreasonable
the diagonal
um i don't know if this is appropriate
or even possible is there any chance of
a
a site visit with one of the officers to
just clearly explain
how it sits in the landscape that you
know that that would i found that really
helpful
i found it quite difficult to work out
when i went on my own and i'm not
particularly familiar with the area and
i'm not great at translating
2d plans into 3d imaginations but i'd
like to i'd like to you know if we're
going to give it another consideration i
think then another approach to it might
be helpful you know make us think
differently about it see it differently
and possibly in some ways
absolutely we can organize that is there
any general interest in that or
just council diagno
yeah i think that's interesting yeah
yeah
well we've got the light at the moment
at this time of year so we could do we
could do that in the evening if if
members wanted to because because we
were able to do so
i think um
but let's work out what the dates for it
um
another time as we could i think because
other people will have difficulties with
with whichever evening we go for i mean
i think um
i i think so i take councillor bunting's
point about not discussing the whole
application again but i don't think we
will be doing that we wouldn't be
looking at the application afresh
we would we could focus our discussion
on
the reasons for refusal that were
advanced um in in the light of the
information that we had and then and
then the new information as well and i
think
outside of the meeting we can certainly
work on
the report and focusing the discussion
towards those reasons for refusal and
arranging a site visit if that is of
interest to to members so i think we can
do all that um outside of the meeting if
we if we do want to bring it back um but
council bunting moved that we that we
don't bring it back that we we don't see
it again i think i don't know if anyone
wants to
se hey sorry go and come to them if i
maybe i have changed my mind in this
meeting in meetings like this more times
than i care to remember that god knows
how many years i've been on this
committee i think uh probably lost what
the council wants as well he's
we i think we've been on this committee
longer than most and i've changed my
mind up ten times and i've seen him for
new information if there is new
information i'm more than happy to look
at it it's just i can't conceive
of what new information would
change such as what i thought was an
absolutely appalling application and
what i think was unreasonable was he
constantly bringing back of
varying degrees of the same application
over and over again uh i will look at
any new information if it is but it
would have to be very if it's a minor
tweak here and there or a minor thing
you know that's not gonna i'm simply
saying we have all how much else are we
gonna have on that agenda for that
evening we have already spent a great
deal of time and therefore offers a
resource
discussing this application and its
predecessor application and how many
more hours are we going to throw at it
yeah i mean i suppose they they
you know they
countervailing argument to that is if
if we don't look at it again then
the advice from council is that we are
at risk is the cost so it might seem
like repeating time but the risk we bear
is is will be on the end of a cost award
against us um councillor walsh she
wanted to leave
chair i i can't remember this ever
happening previously well we've made a
decision
and someone's come back to us and said
we've had advice that we're going to
have all costs awarded against them can
we revisit i've never known that before
um
and it wasn't at the meeting
when it was discussed but it just seemed
to be like
the spirit of the meeting was obviously
to reject it for the reasons that they
said and now we're kind of saying well
we want to we've got to think about it
and how we want to change our minds
about him just
feels don't feel quite right to me to be
to be revisiting it that that there was
that length of discussion and i'm sure
it was pretty heated
but you came to your decision
and it was agreed it took a fall and and
yet we're going back to it and it just
doesn't sit comfortable with me chair i
i can only say say how i feel thank
doesn't look like you
degree of threats of
you must
you you must go
no we've been a bunch of naughty boys
and you must go and start in the corner
and think about how naughty uh let's
let's go cancel the welton please but we
have taken away one of the reasons for
objection and therefore we need to
demand
for some people that may be the case for
other people
it may not i think we deserve
a chance to discuss whether the other
reasons um you know stack up um it was a
finely balanced
i mean i know i changed my mind about
five times in the meeting
over this one so what i mean for for me
it was very finely balanced and i i
you know i i would be interested to to
oh well yeah i don't look forward to it
but
but i would be happy to look at it again
um given that we have taken away one of
the reasons for rejection
miss kohler do you want to um maybe just
advise on the issue that council of wall
street is that this seems very unusual
yes certainly
this this is this is less than usual
than than perhaps um
councillor walsh
thinks in that
it is well firstly for local planning
authorities the whole will quite often
go back to their uh reasons for refusing
the course of an appeal and adjust them
um in the last uh municipal year and
council welsh i appreciate you you had
your mayoral duties at the time
um
you um
we we we did this twice um we removed
the reason for refusing we didn't pursue
an objection to the little uh
application if if members recall again
because of new information because of a
change in circumstances and actually for
the b and q appeal we added a reason
again in the light of new information
coming forward so
um this is a this is a fairly standard
process um for authorities to go through
particularly once you get a barrister on
board um with with a an appeal of this
nature and um
the only thing i would say about about
the time and the point that the council
bunting makes is there would be
significant officer time spent in the
defending of the appeal so
it isn't just um the time spent around
the committee table there is then
obviously a knock-on effect as the
appeal is has to be defended by by
officers thank you
thank you mr councillor procter you
wanted to speak i'll give you the last
word thank you so
completely new to the
whole area of planning
but what concerns me is the council
could end up having to pay masses of
costs
and that makes me think i don't really
care how much it's been discussed before
or even how
um
vocal people have been because the
bottom line is we cannot afford to lose
some money so
and costs could be enormous so even if
no one wants to talk about it again
which i get
we've got to keep an eye on the bottom
line and if it means we spend another
hour talking about it
that's better than paying costs because
the decision that
was made last time
um has some not valid elements and this
comes straight after rebecca's excellent
training
about
what is a right reason to object
that can be upheld and what is
a non-material
consideration
i just don't want us to end up footing
the bill
because we weren't prepared to talk
about it again thanks thank you
okay so uh
i think i moved that we we brought out
and back and i think i think councillor
thomas
was minded secondly but he's had to
leave the meeting so i don't know
when stanley will will second that uh
motion um
so
i think we've got a good discussion on
that and i think in order to
sort of take it further we would need to
explore it at a further meeting but
let's vote on that on that motion which
is whether to bring that item uh back to
the next meeting with a report from
officers to consider the the other
reasons for refusal not not necessarily
to look at the whole application again
so
those in favor of that resolution if you
raise your hands now please
okay
and those against police
okay so that resolution is carried so
we'll bring that back to the next
meeting um
thank you very much for your
contributions on uh
on that item um
so i think it's uh that just leaves us
with uh item 12 which is any urgent
business have not been notified of any
has anybody else got any urgent business
to raise
no
uh he yet we're still we're still
recording and being broadcast
just i know we've agreed to bring the
the previous item back to committee can
i just ask if the fact that it's had
second consideration
um and the decision remains the same or
we did you know
no does it add any weight or any
significance to this decision that it
had that extra time or was that not
making a difference no no no that that
won't make any any difference the
inspector will consider it entirely on
its merit yeah okay all right thank you
very much
yeah understood okay
so that uh
is it is it uh uh urgent business okay
so um it comes out the second time we
look at it again and if we come to the
same conclusion and
do it does it come back a third time
and a fourth and no okay okay
okay we've we've voted on that
resolution already so i think i think
that has brought that item business to
an end and there's no other urgent
business so
um at that point i'm going to declare
the meeting closed but if members could
remain behind please thank you